HURRICANE FIONA
STRENGTHENING AS IT SETS ITS
SIGHTS ON ANOTHER BATCH OF
ISLANDS.
BUT AS IT MOVES PAST PUERTO RICO
AND THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, THE
DAMAGE IS DEVASTATING.
LOOK AT THOSE IMAGES.
IN PUERTO RICO TWO PEOPLE ARE
DEAD THIS MORNING AFTER MOST OF
THE POWER ON THE ISLAND IS OUT.
IT COULD BE DAYS BEFORE IT IS
RESTORED.
>> WE'RE LOOKING FOR GASOLINE,
WATER, ICE.
ALL OF THE SUPPLIES NECESSARY
FOR GETTING THROUGH THIS.
WE WERE HOPING IT WOULDN'T BE SO
BIG.
BUT, WELL, IT WAS BIGGER THAN WE
EXPECTED.
AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE DO WITH
WHAT YOU HAVE.
>> BEEN THROUGH THIS BEFORE.
RESCUERS HAVE SAVED MORE THAN A
THOUSAND PEOPLE FROM THE
FLOODWATERS.
AS MUCH AS 30 INCHES OF RAIN
FELL ON THE EIISLAND.
THAT IS LIKE TWO AND A HALF
FEET.
THEY TRY TO GET TO PEOPLE IN
MORE HARD TO REACH AREAS.
THIS COMES FIVE YEARS, TO THE
DAY AFTER HURRICANE MARIA MADE
LANDFALL ON THE U.S. ISLAND.
MANY PEOPLE WHO LIVED THROUGH
THAT CATASTROPHE FEAR THE
FALLOUT AND THE AFTERMATH FROM
FIONA COULD BE WORSE.
NOW TURKS AND CAICOS, POSSIBLY
NEXT IN THE STORM'S PATH.
THE FIRST MAJOR HURRICANE OF THE
YEAR EXPECTED TO BECOME A
CATEGORY 4 BY TOMORROW.
>> LET'S BRING IN OUR CNN
METEOROLOGIST CHAD MYERS, WHERE
IS THE -- WE SEE WHERE THE STORM
IS HEADED BUT WHAT IS IT
BRINGING?
HOW BAD.
>> IT WENT OVER GRAND TURK.
THAT IS NOT GRACE BAY, THAT IS
THE NEXT KIND OF SET OF ISLANDS
OVER.
BUT WE DO KNOW THERE IS ALREADY
DAMAGE ON SOUTH CAICOS AND EAST
CAICOS.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING VIDEOS OUT OF
THE SOME RESORTS, SO FAR SO
GOOD, THEY'RE GETTING WINDS OF
50 TO 60.
THEY COULD HANDLE THAT.
AND THE HURRICANE HUNTER FINDING
WIND SPEEDS OF ABOUT 103 TO 115.
AND THAT MEANS ROOF OR NO ROOF
LEFT.
SO WE ARE GOING TO SEE THIS
CONTINUE TO GATHER STRENGTH.
140 MILE PER HOUR STORM BY
TOMORROW AND WE'RE STILL GOING
TO SEE RAIN SHOWERS ACROSS PARTS
OF PUERTO RICO.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS STORM IS
THAT IT WAS MOVING AT 8 MILES
PER HOUR.
AND THAT IS HOW YOU GOT SO MUCH
FLOODING.
THAT IS HOW YOU GOT 32 INCHES OF
RAIN IN PONCE.
THAT IS THE BOTTOM 10% OF HOW
FAST STORMS SHOULD BE MOVING
AWAY.
JUST DIDN'T WANT TO MOVE AWAY.
IT JUST CONTINUES TO WANT TO
RAIN.
A LITTLE BIT OF RAIN TODAY,
MAYBE AN INCH OR TWO.
BUT THIS IS NOW MOVED AWAY FROM
PUERTO RICO.
MOVING AWAY FROM THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC.
NOT SEEING A LOT OF RAIN ON THE
SOUTH SIDE OF THE D.R.
BUT THERE IS THE STORM RIGHT
NOW.
NOT SEEING A REALLY DEFINED EYE
AND THAT IS GOOD.
THAT MEANS IT IS NOT GAINING
RAPID INTENSIFICATION.
BUT HERE IS WHAT IS GOING TO GO
ON.
WE'RE GOING TO GET A STORM
SURGEON THE CAICOS AND MOVE
TOWARD THE NORTH.
AND MAYBE EVEN TOWARD BERMUDA.
YOU'RE IN THE CONE, BERMUDA, BUT
NOT IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
THE MODELS ARE INDICATING A LEFT
TURN INTO CANADA.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WITH A
DIFFERENT STORM A FEW YEARS AGO
THAT MADE A LEFT TURN.
WE DON'T LIKE LEFT TURNS.
>> YEAH.
CHAD MYERS, I THINK YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SANDY THERE?
>> I DIDN'T WANT TO MENTION IT.
>> OKAY, FAIR ENOUGH.
BAD MEMORIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'
WE'LL BE WATCHING CLOSELY.
>>> JOINING ME NOW FROM PUERTO
RICO, SERGIO FLO, SERGIO AND I
WENT TO COLLEGE TOGETHER.
IT IS GOOD TO TALK TO YOU THIS
MORNING.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU AN THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU'VE BEEN DEEP ON THIS
ISSUE OF PUERTO RICO'S RECOVERY
FROM MARIA BUT ALSO JUST THE
BROADER ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
I WANT TO START BY ASKING, HOW
ARE PEOPLE DOING THERE RIGHT
NOW?
WHAT IS THE SITUATION TODAY AND
DOES IT COMPARE TO WHAT WE SAW
FIVE YEARS AGO?
>> WELL, FIRST THING WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IS THAT THE DAMAGE OF
THIS CAUSED BY ANY STORM IS NOT
ONLY A FUNCTION OF THE STRENGTH
OF THE STORM, BUT ALSO HOW
PREPARED YOU ARE.
HOW VULNERABLE IS THE
POPULATION.
AN WE'RE NOT IN THE STRONGEST
POSITION TO WEATHER THIS STORM.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE LIKE AROUND
80% OF THE POPULATION WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY, AROUND 65% WITHOUT
WATER.
25% DON'T HAVE CELL PHONE
SERVICE.
APPROXIMATELY 2,000 PEOPLE ARE
IN SHELTERS AND WE HAVE GOT IN
OVER 30 INCHES OF RAIN IN SOME
AREAS AS YOU REPORTED.
SO THERE IS WIDESPREAD FLOODING
AND A LOT OF DAMAGE TO ROADS AND
BRIDGES AND COMMERCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOMES.
SO WE HAVE OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR
US.
SO RELATIVE TO MARIA, THE FACT
THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IS PROOF OR
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE DONE SOME
THINGS RIGHT.
BACK THEN FOR EXAMPLE, NOBODY
HAD ACCESS TO CELL PHONE OR
INTERNET.
SO WE DID SOME THINGS RIGHT.
BUT WE DO HAVE SAY LOT OF WORK
IN FRONT OF US.
>> YOU HAVE SAID THAT THE POWER
GRID IN PUERTO RICO, YOU'VE
DESCRIBED IT AS FUNCTIONAL BUT
FRAGILE.
AND I WONDER, ARE WE SEEING THAT
HERE?
THAT THE REPAIRS DONE IN THE
WAKE OF MARIA WERE NOT
SUFFICIENT TO PREVENT FOLKS
LOSING POWER AGAIN.
>> YES.
DEFINITELY.
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER MARIA, WE
FINISHED THE EMERGENCY REPAIRS
WHICH TOOK ABOUT A YEAR BY THE
WAY.
THEY WERE FINALIZED AROUND
AUGUST OF 2018.
AND THEN ON THE SECOND STAGE OF
THE PROCESS WHEN WE START
THINKING ABOUT MAKING THE GRID
MORE SILL YENT AND STRENGTHENING
IT, WE HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS AND
WE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS WITH
FEMA.
BUT VERY LITTLE PROGRESS MADE
DUE TO VERY -- SEVERAL DIFFERENT
REASONS.
BUT THE FACT IS THAT THE GRID
HAS A LOT OF PATCHES AND THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
IT HASN'T BEEN STRENGTHED OR
MADE MORE RESILIENT SINCE MARIA.
>> WE HAVE HAD A FORMER STATE
SENATOR ON LAST HOUR WHO SAID
THAT OF THE $10 BILLION OR SO
GIVEN TO PUERTO RICO POST MARIA,
THAT THE ONLY ABOUT $40 MILLION
OF $10 BILLION HAS BEEN SPENT SO
FAR.
HE BLAMED RED TAPE AND SAID THAT
A LOT OF THAT BURDEN FALLS ON
PUERTO RICO AND I WONDER IF YOU
AGREE OF THAT.
WHY HASN'T MORE OF THAT AID BEEN
SPENT TO HELP PREVENT THESE KIND
OF CONSEQUENCES?
>> THAT IS A NUMBER THAT HAS
BEEN SPENT ON WHAT FEMA CALLS
PERMANENT WORKS, LONG-TERM
PROJECTS TO STRENGTHEN THE GRID.
AND I THINK THERE IS A LOT --
THERE IS A LOT OF BLAME TO GO
AROUND.
PART OF IT IS ON PUERTO RICO.
PART OF IT IS ON, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT --
>> YEAH.
>> AND ALSO THERE IS A LACK OF
AGREEMENT HOW TO PRECISELY
REBUILD THE GRADE TO MAKE IT
MORE RESILIENCE.
THIS IS A BIG DEBATE.
AND THIS IS HAPPENED EVERYWHERE,
BETWEEN RENEWABLES AND NATURAL
GAS.
THE FOSSIL FUELS LOBBY IS STRONG
EVERYWHERE.
SO IT IS NOT A SURPRISE THAT
WE'RE FACING A LOT OF PRESSURE
JUST TO REBUILD TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM MORE RESILIENT.
WHILE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> WHAT DO FOLKS NEED MOST RIGHT
NOW?
I'M SURE A LOT OF FOLKS WATCHING
OUR AIR NOW ARE SEEING PEOPLE IN
NEED.
WHAT IS MOST URGENT?
>> WELL MOST URGENT IS TO GET
WATER, FOOD AND ANY MEDICAL
TREATMENT TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
LIVING IN ISOLATED COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED TO WORK ON THE DEBRIS
REMOVAL, OPEN ROADS, MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS SAFE TO MOVE AROUND
THE ISLAND.
FINISH ANY EMERGENCY RESCUE
OPERATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
FINISHED.
AS YOU SAW FROM THE VISUALS,
THERE IS A LOT OF FLOODING.
STILL IN THE ISLAND, WE'RE
EXPECTING SOME MORE RAIN SOON.
SO, THOSE ARE TOP OF MIND RIGHT
NOW TO ME IN TERMS OF WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE IMMEDIATELY.
>> SERGIO, WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING IN PUERTO
RICO.
WE WISH YOU AND THE PEOPLE THERE
THE VERY BEST.